-Welcome back, everybody.
I'm here are Tariq Trotter
from the Roots.
And we are about to face off
in the first-ever
"Tonight show" Ford Electric
Cooler Scooter Race.
Here we go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, we will each be riding
these custom-made
scooter sleighs,
which match the two
new Ford Mustang Mach-E SUVs
parked downstairs
here at 30 Rockefeller Plaza.
I am riding red.
Tariq is riding blue.
They've been charging both of
these scooters all day long.
And I've been told
they can go upwards
of 3 to 5 miles per hour.
-Whoo!
-So let's be careful out there,
Tariq.
Alright.
Here's how the race works.
We're going to head out
these doors, okay?
Past Hashtag the Panda,
who is untangling a ball
of Christmas lights.
Then we're gonna go towards the
elevators, loop around Santa,
who is charging his sleigh with
a Ford electric charging
station.
We'll turn back down the hallway
past an ugly Christmas sweater
party.
Then we'll be careful
to avoid the gingerbread houses
in the dangerous
Gingerbread Man's Curve.
And for the last leg
of the race,
we have to drive through
the Christmas tree car wash...
then dodge snowballs
thrown by an angry yeti.
The first one
to make it back to the studio
and smash through
the pyramid of presents
will win and be the champion.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
-That good?
-Yeah.
-Higgins, count us down.
-Are you guys ready?
-Yes.
-One, two, three, go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Indistinct conversation ]
♪♪
-Alright. Where are you?
I can feel you.
Whah!
♪♪
-Aah! [ Laughs ]
-Be careful.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Crashed.
-What are you doing?
[ Laughter ]
-Someone call the police.
-You ran me off the road, man.
-Oh, my God. This is hilarious.
Hey. Someone call 911.
-My gosh.
-Now you got it in reverse.
-My gosh. I got this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo!
♪♪
-Aah!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughing ]
♪♪
-Whoo!
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-We did it!
Whoo!
-Just like rehearsal.
-Yep. Perfect.
-Oh, my gosh. Congratulations.
Get off that thing.
Congratulations.
Tariq Trotter is the winner.
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you!
-Ohh. Oh, my God.
That was really fun.
But we're not finished.
We want to pick someone special
from the audience
to help us with this next part.
Simone Beadie?
Simone Beadie? Are you there?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi. Nice to meet you.
-Nice to meet you.
-Jimmy. That's Tariq.
-Nice to meet you, too.
-Simone, is it Baity or Beadie?
-It's Beadie.
-Simone Beadie.
I got it right. Good.
Simone, where are you from?
-I am from Northern Virginia,
like the D.C. area.
-Oh, very cool.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And what do you do for a living?
-I am a middle-school
math teacher.
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love math teachers. Thank you
so much for being here.
We actually knew
that you were coming tonight.
We talked to people
before the show started.
It's the holiday season,
which is all about giving
and helping those in need.
So our friends at Ford
and the Ford Motor Company Fund
will be donating $100,000
to Feeding America.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And can we look
at those cars again?
They're also -- They filled
the Mustang Mach-E
front trunks, or "frunks,"
with food that will be donated
in your name
to a local
Feeding America food bank.
-Ohh! Thank you so much.
That's awesome.
-Feels good for the holidays.
Go to feedingamerica.org
to find out how you can make
a difference
in your own community.
Thank you so much, Simone.
Thank you for being here.
-Thank you so much.
-I appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll be right --
Actually, wait. Hold a second.
Simone, while you're here,
one more thing.
Ford wants to do something else
special for you.
That's why they're giving you
a brand-new, all-electric
Ford Mustang Mach-E!
-Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Goodbye, gas. Hello, freedom.
The high-performance,
all-electric
Ford Mustang Mach-E SUV
gives you zero-to-60
exhilaration,
expansive range,
and zero tailpipe emissions,
with the kind of horsepower,
torque, and acceleration
to make you feel like a champion
the moment you slide
into the driver's seat.
The Ford Mach-E.
This ain't no one-trick pony.
Jimmy!
-My thanks to everyone at Ford.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with Regina Hall, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪